Oh my god, I'm so sorry Oh, we crash, we crash We're just
gonna have If we crash, we crash If we have crashes every 15
minutes That's just the way of life It's the Doki life Doki
Brit has never been lucky I work very hard But sometimes
life just goes Fuck you Never been lucky in life I've
accepted it.
I basically, what I, I basically remade everything.
I had to remake everything.
I even deleted my old scene collection.
I deleted my fucking normal streaming collection.
Like, so, cause I was just like, oh no, what's going on?
Cause it always, it does, I don't know, it does happen very
off, like not very often, but it's like random.
If I make a new scene collection, sometimes it works and
sometimes it doesn't.
But it hits at like the most random moments.
when it hits it crashes every 15 minutes like obs in general
it crashes every 15 minutes so like it's so hard to like
sometimes predict when it's gonna happen and then like while
i was standing up it didn't hit until like when i was about
to start the stream and then when it hit i was like oh fuck
okay i'm gonna try to do the fast way because usually the
fast way is like a 50 50 chance for it to work so that was
like okay i'm gonna do it the fast way maybe the fast way
will be fine and then obviously we had to wait 15 minutes
and then i was like oh it did not work the fast way did not
work so i guess i'll just do the slow way but the slow way
isn't guarantee either it just has a higher percentage of
guaranteeing anyway to be fair to be fair what i'm
announcing oh my gosh there's so much work that went into
this i'm just i i don't know i hope i got everything i hope
like i got everything in because like i had to set up really
really fucking fast so like i don't even know if i set
everything up properly i don't i was just like okay
everything looks i think everything's in And then I just
went, oh, fuck it, we bawled.
We fucking bawled.
Guys, I swear, I'm going to set my new PC today or tomorrow.
It's just there's so many things going on.
So I didn't have time to do anything.
What's happening?
That's a very good question.
I bet you guys are all very, very curious as to what this
announcement's going to be.
I mean, of course, it could be anything.
answers only and i saw a lot of people giving so many
different answers you someone actually got it right someone
was like wrong answer but then it was actually the right
answer so it's fucking crazy why do you guys actually got
the answer correct while we were giving wrong answer only so
it was very interesting to see hey guys all right i mean i
could like bait you guys longer I could like make you guys
wait even longer, but we you guys already waited 36 minutes.
So Let's do a countdown.
Let's get a drum roll, please.
Drum roll everybody.
10, 9, 8, 7.
It'll be so funny if I crash this moment.
Knowing me, this, I fucking can jinx myself.
8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Oh,
yes, everybody!
WrestleTuber is here!
Yeah!
No, I didn't mute my mic.
I just let you guys enjoy the moment, you know?
Just like absorb the moment as you see the logo.
So you might be noticing something in the backdrop that's
different other than just the WrestleTuber logo.
But this whole event will be sponsored.
by gamer subs in a way where basically i didn't have to pay
for anything so so a huge shout out to gamer subs for
providing the funding for the graphics um uh for the uh for
the wrestling belts like you hear the plural belts and other
goodies so gamer subs is the official sponsor for wrestle um
some of you guys might be wondering what is wrestle tuber um
but before i answer that i just need you guys to know
there's so many like last minute things that happened uh
before this announcement that like i literally was like
scrounging up the last couple of details like two hours
before this stream was supposed to air because like there
was some last minute additions and there was also um there
was also like some uh we were actually was gonna have a
video to like show it and stuff just like the uh the logo
but because there's so many last minute additions a video
was not made in time and i hope the video editor is okay
because i was like i'm so sorry we have some last minute
additions to be made and because of that uh the the the
videos video was not done in time but it was it's it's a
really sick video so when it is done i cannot wait to show
you guys
anyway yes wrestle tuber 2024 i feel like you guys will be
like wanting to know the one thing you guys really want to
know at the moment is who is participating um let's just say
it is honestly one of the hardest fucking event i've ever
organized ever because there's so many people from different
backgrounds different companies either company or indie and
like trying to coordinate with so many different people um
and then like trying to grab information and grabbing um and
grabbing like graphics and everything i i sometimes i even
got like graphics uh during the Before the stream I got some
of the graphics the last five and then like poking people be
like hey I know you wanted to join but like I really need
the graphics Like please please I can you please send me the
graphics and I don't know or like be like Hey like thank you
for joining but like I really need to know like if you're
making your wrestler or like if the fans Making it and like
I need to know if you're joining this section of the
tournament or if you're joining this part Please, I really
need to know the reply.
I'm announcing this in five hours
I was like, please, please I'm announcing this today and
I'll be like, please I'm announcing it tomorrow Can you
provide me the information?
And then the next day, like, please I'm announcing it today
I really need the information
I swear this is absolutely one of the hardest events I've
ever organized only because because there's just so many
different people from different backgrounds and trying to
grab information, trying to grab intel, like trying to try
to grab graphics, trying to court scheduling too.
Oh my gosh, I'm so sorry if you don't see some of your like
Yoshi, if you don't see your Yoshi or your content creator,
like a content creator you actually really wanted to see in
WrestleTuber, um, that's not there.
Scheduling was so fucking hard.
And I also had to cap it too, that cap it at one point and
then I had and then like we had like uh maybe like one or
two people dropped out because the scheduling wise for
everybody was different and because of that because there's
like I said it's different companies or like indies and then
everybody has different scheduling and then there's like
conventions going on there's like other stuff going on
within that company so because of that um because of that we
had like moments where like maybe like somebody dropped out
and then because like the skit we had to change the dates
for the event uh and all oh my gosh it was a lot i need you
guys to know this is fully organized and prepared by me only
there's no team behind it despite gamer subs is sponsoring
this i've organized all of this myself like every
information setting up the discord server to people all of
this was done by me and me only so i like i didn't want to
make this like an like a super serious i didn't want to make
this like a super serious like uh uh like very official uh
tournament thing i wanted to be like a fun unifying event
within the i guess like the this was my idea in making
something like more relaxing for everybody and more so of
just like a big event because I feel like a lot of things
that we lack in the western v-tubing side is an event that
uh that that basically unites uh different v-tubers from
different backgrounds different areas like company or and
indie because that's what we see in Japan we have like
crazy raccoon we have vault room as well in japan i feel
like in the western side and the english vtubing sphere we
don't even we don't really have stuff like this and um this
was actually something i've been planning on doing um it was
in my roadmap actually this was actually like in my roadmap
when it came to like where i wanted to go when it came to
organizing like events and this would be the very first time
i'm doing something like this from uh doing something like
this regarding having a big event that doesn't require any
skill so like anybody can join um um and like anybody can
join anybody can uh because all of this is gonna be wrestle
tube for those who don't know wrestle tuber uh you might
remember a previous uh previous version of this event and is
practically a spiritual successor of that event and uh it
will be run on the wwe 2k24 edition of the game and
basically vtubers uh this is primarily for vtubers uh uh
from different companies or not company you know indies uh
coming together to um to be at during the interviews in the
pre and post interview and then they're and then they'll
have wrestlers that they're going to embody but it'll be cpu
controlled uh but they will be there a lot of these all
these vtubers that are participating will be here um and the
broadcast staff is actually uh a bunch of vtubers from
different places so you know uh we'll have like maybe like
some vtubers vtubers in the
And also, like I said, there will be every participant in
WrestleTuber will receive a little small care package to
thank them for participating and to thank them for, like,
you know, joining this event just because like, you know,
they're giving up their very own time to participate in
this.
There's like nobody's getting paid.
And then the broadcast staff, because I promised them
because I felt like, you know, since the main broadcast is
on my channel, I told the broadcast staff like any amount,
any of the donations.
the super chats that come in during the event will be split
between the broadcast staff just because it's fair and uh i
might put in a little extra as well because i feel like you
know they're giving up their time to be there to cast to
participate as the announcer to do the interview and stuff
like that so i'll be giving them some of the earnings from
the event anyway the rules one of the things you guys might
be wondering the rules basically I talked about the rules a
little bit already so let me just reiterate some of some of
it alright let me rules so the official hashtag as you guys
all saw let me shimmy over here there you let me shimmy over
so the official hashtag is 2024.
So you can use this hashtag to submit your wrestlers,
illustrations, and Latui.
The event will be held on May 25th and 26th.
So Saturday and Sunday if you're in NA, Saturday and Sunday
at 4 p.m.
PST.
There will also be, this is going to be a new edition, but
show matches.
So for those who couldn't, for some of the YouTubers,
obviously they couldn't commit their full time because,
they're going to be eliminated like that is the whole
randomness of this whole event we don't know when they're
going to be eliminated so we gave an options for the
participants to basically um we gave an option for the
participants to basically uh decide if they want to show up
at the show matches which will be in the beginning of each
day and each of those participants that chose the show match
won't have to participate for one match and it'll be like
maybe like cage matches or tag And we don't, like, it will
be announced during the event, the main broadcast.
So that will be, like, a surprise for the audience as to
what the show match is going to be.
So there is two formats for this.
Tournament run, obviously, it's, like, the full-on
tournament structure.
So, like, obviously, you know, they go until they're
eliminated.
And that is why it runs for two days, because it is very
long.
had a hard cap but then like we got beyond the hard cap so
so it ended up not being a hard cap anymore so because I
because there's some last-minute additions in there and I
was like fuck it let them in anyway as I said before the
wrestlers will be CPU controlled but all participants will
be there for interviews and or broadcast staff so until
they're eliminated type deal so they will be like showing up
on stream uh doing the interviews and like roasting each
other all of that stuff so they will be there in some way um
main broadcast will be on this channel but some participants
will stream their own wrestling creation before the event so
they some of them have decided to have chosen to create
their own wrestler and they will be making that wrestler
themselves on the stream for the fans to watch and i like i
said before this will be an event that unites vtubers from
different backgrounds whether indie or company and represent
the spirit of vtubing because like i like i wanted i wanted
to do an event i feel like we are very lacking this in the
western vtuber side there's a lot of events that combines
like vtubing and like fleshy's together but like there's not
a lot of event that combines like v-tubing from different
companies as well or indies uh together to uh participate in
something uh big a great fun event uh and this was something
i wanted to do and we see a lot of that in japan but we
don't see really see that much in uh in like the western
side and that is what that was like my goal in doing this
hey guys before I show my the second rules page I feel like
a lot of guys want to know who are on the teams when I show
you guys the teams who are always on a team sorry the
participant participating members so there's actually two
slides to the participating members but I'll it'll show the
first slide I'll be showing the first slide first obviously
uh because there was a lot of them I think we have 29 people
29 participants in total um obviously like there was
originally a super uh there was originally a super hard cap
but uh but it uh but it ended up going beyond that
so so so that's why we had 29 in the end But not all 29
wrestlers will be doing the tournament structure.
Some of them will be in show matches.
So that's why you must be like, 29, that's not even enough
for the tournament.
But that is because not all 29 of them are going to be in
the tournament.
Some of them are just going to be participating in the show
match.
And like I said earlier, if you don't see your OSHA, you
don't see your V2, I'm really sorry.
There was like, there was a lot.
There was a lot of interest.
And, like, at that point, like, I also didn't want to have,
like, too many from one sector.
So, like, and obviously, like, some, obviously, other areas,
there might not be a lot of interest was there regarding
that.
So there was a lot of interest in certain companies, and
there was a lot of interest within the indie sphere.
But I tried to balance it as best as I could.
And then obviously there were moments where like some of the
companies had their own events during this time or like
during that date and or And because of that they weren't
able to participate some like VTubers that wanted to
participate couldn't participate due to the Overlapping the
schedule so within like either company wise or Or just like
within their own individual schedule.
Anyway, team's time.
It's team teams time wow all right so this is slide number
one um i need you guys to know um um like i said i reached
out um to a bunch of companies um because i really wanted to
um i reached out to a bunch of companies and i said like
okay there is a limit to how many per company can send and
uh and i obviously I really wanted to reach out to prison
like ex-prison project uh uh to participate in this uh in
this event uh because of everything that happened so I
reached out to one of the members in ex-prison project and
asked if they wanted to be in uh in WrestleTuber um really
happy to have yeah we there was actually a lot of interest
but unfortunately we had to cap it uh as I said like because
I didn't want to have like like one had spread it out more
evenly uh amongst the amongst the participants regarding
like which uh which like i'm writing like how many can each
company send so there was a hard limit for each company um
so like i said uh there are the participants in prison
ex-prison project um nia sarah emma uh luto asteria and non
and then in v show jo we have zentrea uh for the indies we
have saiyu phillian buff puff me shy lily limu maryweather
snuffy and nirosama um so this is uh there's a slide two
guys there's a slide two because we have 29.
there is a slide two
I feel like people are like, oh my god, what's in slide two?
I'm like, even I'm anxious.
Even I'm fucking anxious on slide two.
But anyway, here is slide two.
So we have Idol EN, Phase Connect, and Hollow Stars
participating.
And you guys know, Axel, Axel.
I was talking to Axel and this was at hello stars.
This was actually the last minute edition They joined the
server.
I think three days ago and I had to re not redo everything
But I had to scrounge up a lot of stuff So so huge shout out
to Axel for helping me with this because I asked him like do
you I'm organizing wrestle tuber i was wondering if you're
you guys are interested like um obviously you guys don't
have to join it's just a little fun thing i'm doing um but
there's gonna be a lot of people from different areas um in
b-tubing and then axel was came got back to me and was like
oh my gosh so many of the boys are interested and i was like
yeah bring people to join in and then uh so anyway so hello
stars was actually one of the last the last minute entry
into wrestle tuber and so we have a lot of people in rest
like at after the last hollow stars member got into the
server i was like all right we're capping i was like okay we
are we're we got a hard cap this now
so um um but yes it would uh so we have hollow stars we have
uh Aksa, Haka, Beto, Gerard, Octavia, Gold Bullet, and
Shinri from Holostars.
In Idol Yen, we have Juna, Fuyo, Kai, and Rin.
And finally, in Phase Connect, we have Saya and Rumiya.
So these are the 29 participants that will be participating
in WrestleTuber.
Like I said before, I'm really sorry we don't see your Oshi
or VTuber.
restituber it was very hard to like um it was very hard to
like limit participants as well as like when we came to
sending out invites and stuff at one point we sent out
invites to certain vtubers um but uh because they were very
busy they weren't able to reply back in time um or like the
invite got lost so uh there were some uh there was also some
vtubers that uh originally was were but because we had to
change the date last minute we had some vtubers that
couldn't participate due to the change of the date so um and
of course there was also like obviously we had limited spots
and because of that uh we had to well i had to because like
i'm the sole organizer
i am the sole organizer so i made the decision with myself,
the board, which is myself.
That regarding like regarding like who can and who like
regarding like like when who to invite and like oh like what
do we do with this?
The board as in me and me only.
The dokey board.
I am the Senate.
Anyway, now you guys are wondering who is on the broadcast
staff so on the broadcast staff we have um the interviewer
will be juna uh juna unangi from idol en the announcer will
be saiyu uh the casters will be me snuffy phillian octavio
and gold bullet uh so that is uh the broadcast staff team uh
for the 25th and the 26th brought i'm so sorry gold bullet
i'm so i'm like blocking you
but here is here is the broadcast staff um just so you guys
know for the casters um it's not going to be like all of us
are just going to be on the casting table the reason why the
casting the casting table is uh the cat there's a lot of
people in the casting uh broadcasting table is so that we
can basically mix and match in between.
So because of that, it allows us to, like, for the, we don't
have, like, you know, one, two, like all of us don't have
the fucking cast all the way through.
We can take breaks in between and like mix and match the
combinations of the casters.
So like, and so like it allows us to rest a bit in between
and take breaks.
Because that was like one of the things I realized that
having a small pool of casters is not really like the best
because like what if we want to take a break and it's very
long the thing is this is a very this is going to be a very
long event due to how many participants there are so so it's
good to be able to mix and match the casters because in the
end I remember I had like set casters for like certain days
but for this one we're going to be mixing in between it's
not gonna be mixed every match or so like maybe like this
combination will do like uh three to four like two three to
four matches and then you know and then like later on we go
in with a new combination for three to four matches and uh
that is how it's gonna be also finally credits uh uh we have
this might be a very familiar team um because i love working
with these people um when i do like projects and events i
tend to work with the same people because they know what i
like they know what i want and um i know they do a really
good job uh so like i said there is uh the logo was done by
ss sugar type um you see here the wrestle tuber uh the bell
will be designed by melie uh we will be showing you guys the
design of the belt at a later stage um at a stage of the uh
like when it gets closer to the event i guess uh when it get
closer to the event the belt design will be shown there will
be multiple belts why multiple because those that won the
show matches will also be sent a belt so the winners of the
show matches will get their own belt as well as well as the
tournament uh and uh and like i said um everybody that
participates and souvenir from me um to thank them for
participating so everybody gets something and gamer subs
will be sponsoring all of this so gamer subs is paying for
all the the gifts as well as the belts the graphics um
basically anything that uh that needs to be paid for this
event is paid for by gamer subs so huge shout out to them
because like it's a lot of stuff I felt it's actually crazy
the amount of support for my very first big event.
And finally, OniPilot for designing all the graphics that
you see here for WrestleTuber.
Yay!
All right, finally, rules.
Before, it's not over yet, guys.
It's not over yet because we still have the matchups that we
have to do, the brackets scenario,
Almost forgot to show you guys rules two and three All
right, rules two and three Where's rules two?
All right, rules two Wrestlers will be created in WWE 2K24
The deadline for the wrestler's submission will be May 24th
So it's the day before the event is for both the VTubers
that are creating the wrestlers and for the fan submissions.
So just remember like if you're making when we, I will be
giving a list of the VTubers that will be using your fan
submission wrestler and the deadline will be May 24th.
The wrestlers have to be male so that they can all wrestle
each other in the tournament.
So They have to be male.
Just because that's the only way.
There's no like in the tournament structure.
You can't put like female male wrestlers together.
So we have to decide like it has to be all male.
For stats.
Sorry I forgot to lock myself in.
Please have the attributes have an overall range of 85.
It has to be 85.
It can't be 84.
It can't be 86.
It has to be 85.
So when you're doing all your stats configuration, 85 has to
be the overall stat.
When uploading your wrestler, please use these tags,
WrestleTuber2024, VTubers, VT WWE, and like I said, WWE
2K24.
This is the game that we will be using for.
the tournament structure we will using the steam version
with all the dlc you don't have to have the dlc um we you
don't have that the dlc if you're creating a wrestler but
like if you have the dlc it's just more customization so
like i'll be using the dlc for those who are using dlc just
in case like you know like if i don't have it we won't be
able to download the wrestler so i'll be using all the dlc
so you can go wild with your customization finally when
you're customizing your will be posting the rules on twitter
later so do not worry if you're like oh my god i can't write
all this down there's too much information what am i gonna
do it's way too much information oh my god i can't write
this down in time these are the things you need to customize
uh the the streamers that are making the wrestler will also
know that these i set up a guide i made like a step-by-step
guide for everybody on how they customize and stuff for well
not for you guys i assume you guys know but like a lot of
the people that joined this they haven't played wwe 2k uh
2-4 yet so like didn't know like how to create their custom
rest of there so i basically like wrote a step-by-step guide
for everybody in the server regarding like how to do this
anyway uniformly customized the superstar entrance victory
and moveset video is not required it's not mandatory but if
you do it be funny because like you can put any video in the
backdrop obviously it has to be like if you're gonna do a
video in the backdrop please make it to us friendly
especially the fan submission as long as it's tos friendly
it's fine that's all that's all i asked for it now now rules
number will be creating the wrestler on stream and who will
be using fan submitted wrestlers.
Rules 3.
Alright.
So, these are the people that will be making their wrestler
on stream.
So, you might be seeing, you might notice that I also gave
like two weeks leeway this time around instead of one week.
Because I felt like one week was too short.
one week was um honestly uh way too short so that's why like
people who are making their own wrestler um they can have
they can it's easier to schedule for everybody so um so we
gave everyone two weeks to create their own wrestler so here
are the people that are making it on stream uh Nia, Rin,
Fuyo, Arac, Luto, Kai, Beto, Gerard, Remilia, Non, Limu,
Shinri, Sarah, Octavio, and Meriwether.
These are, you're going to be seeing streams of the people
making their wrestler on those channels.
So please feel free to visit their channels to see them
customize their very own wrestler.
All right, these are the participants that will be using
your wrestler, including me, I don't have time to make my
own.
I'm sorry.
As much as I would love to stream the wrestler creation with
all you guys, I'm sorry.
I don't have time.
I barely have time to set up my own PC guy.
Yorosama, Axel, Sayu, Buff, Buff, Snuffy, Haka, Me, Sia,
Shai Lily, Gold Bullet, Juna, Emma, and Phillion.
These are the people that will be using your wrestlers.
So if you're making a wrestler for us to use, please make
wrestlers for these people, including me.
You can make as many as you guys want.
They will be picking the wrestler to represent themselves.
So like, you know, obviously they'll try and pick the one
that looks the best.
Like looks, I don't know.
like i let them pick the wrestler that they want to
represent them so maybe they'll be like oh this one looks so
fucking funny so i'll use that so obviously the use though
try to i don't know try to see what you think they would
want because some of them will actually be talking on stream
about what kind of wrestler they want to represent them so
uh i know like buff puff puff puff was gonna talk on stream
about like oh what kind of wrestler she uh they want to see
and then um and then like several other streamers are going
to be doing that as well so maybe take some notes and see
what they decide they want to see in to have a wrestler
wrestler represent them all right funny it's time it's
fucking time it's matchup time so i realized there was one
thing i did miss in which was to let you guys know who will
be participating in the show matches and who will be
participating in the tournament i'll actually i'll just like
read out the list of the show matches to you right now
because i didn't write it down i knew i forgot to write down
something so um these are people that will be only
participating in these show matches as in they'll only be
there for the beginning for one match and then they'll have
to it's due to scheduling like i said a lot of this is due
to scheduling and the fact that like you know for some it's
like some people are in eu so they couldn't stay up for too
long uh because like we don't know when this is going to end
so they're like oh yeah like at this point like they're like
oh yeah i don't know if i can stay up for that long so i'll
be there for the beginning for the show matches or just it
was just like time constraints and scheduling um so some of
you chose the show matches um the participants in show
matches will be uh
Zentrea and Shy Lily we have six wrestlers that will only be
there for the show matches also per tradition at the very
end we will have a free for all wrestling free for all
wrestling event with everybody in the end for like the
ultimate wrestler so we will be included they might not be
there spirit they might not be there in the call when this
happens but they will be there spiritually because we'll
throw them in for the free for all anyway it's time for the
brackets but oh my gosh I'm so long since I did like
announcement I'm since I did like announcement streams yeah
alright I'm pulling up the wheel alright one of the things
that I wasn't able to make in time was like I actually made
like a a like a text like text and OBS for everybody's names
that are in the tournament I didn't manage to make that in
time only managed to make one name so we're doing it live
there will be no spinning the wheel for there will be no
spinning the wheel for the show matches that will be a
surprise for everybody.
I guess for the wrestlers as well.
So the show matches, wrestlers will be a surprise as to who
is going to be matched up with who.
Because it can be anything.
It could be cage matches.
It could be tag team.
It could be literally anything.
Because there's so many different types of matches.
So the wheel.
It is the wheel.
Um, all right, let's spin the wheel.
Who will be the first one?
Let's spin the wheel.
All right.
La malicious.
Yay.
Oh my gosh, you guys can't see.
Guys, sorry.
It's the transparency, but you guys can see it's la
malicious.
I'm sorry.
It's a little hard to see because I put on the transparency.
transparency
all right Ramu who is Limu gonna be wrestling all right
let's see okay we're gonna put it all the way up here too by
the way La Malicious up here all right all right Kai Sakota
all right Limu versus Kai let me God I wish I didn't have to
I wish I didn't have have to like fucking remake this i
spent like 10 minutes fucking putting everybody's names in
only for my obs to be like no so now i have to rewrite
everything that's like the worst part
all right the very first i think this will be the very first
match for day one uh we're gonna be the match orders are
gonna be going into this order so like this would be the
first the opening well not the opening match because we do
have um we do have show matches but this will be the first
match for the tournament uh but yes indie versus idol en all
right second matchup
i'm very excited for the roasting i gave like guidelines on
like what to do for like roasting and i gave examples so i
had like one with like logan paul and that other guy like
talking shit and so i had like i sent like examples i'll be
like hey guys it'd be great if you want to hype up the event
to like post like like videos of of like you guys roasting
your matchup and stuff you know all right emma we have emma
for the second match all right duplicate oh my gosh there's
so many people this is gonna take for it Alright, we have
Emma.
Who is Emma gonna fight?
Alright, rename this real fast.
Alright, who the heck is Emma gonna fight?
Remove Emma from the wheel.
Who is the dungeon boss gonna fight?
Who is she gonna fight?
Wait, is it Fuyo?
Fuyo Cloverfeet!
Wait, it could be... Oh, wait, no!
RIN!
Alright.
Alright, dungeon boss versus British prince.
We'll see who's gonna win.
exciting part is seeing like chat bet on who's gonna win
each matchup that's like one of the most exciting parts i
think during uh wrestling events all right rina penrose will
be her opponent finally third match third match of day one
but this guys we're gonna be spinning the wheel forever
there's so many names
gambling legally because we don't lose actual money I swear
if you guys make like actual like what is it called the
sports bet like fantasy sports bets because like I noticed
like people do that for like esports too like apex and stuff
I will not be surprised if someone starts an underground
like betting pool for wrestle tuber
now there's a third match of the day all right duplicate
there you go Anastaria all right who is she gonna fight
totally that's not please please if you're gonna do that
please do not include me
Gerard team Rexford our first hollow stars um a dino and uh
and a falling in a star fight together all right see where
the fuck is this where the fuck is the the tag oh my gosh
you can't be like to remake all of this wait where did it go
guys i'm sorry i'm scuffed right now all right jirai versus
nana syria the dino versus the oh wait isn't the asteroid
wait she's an asteroid too wait this is lore accurate you're
right
rematch rematch history rematch who will win dinosaur versus
asteroid all right and then next the fourth match of the day
Foyoke Cloverfield all right who's Foyoke gonna play Foyle
Cloverfield I'm so sorry for the transparency Or accurate
What happens to the Thanos though Gerard survived What are
we guys talking about Gerard's alive Clearly Gerard survived
the asteroid somehow Like how else would Would Gerard be
alive It's more like It's more like Asteria Fucking
finishing the job After she finds out there was a survivor.
She's back to finish the job.
No survivors.
He was off planet.
Snuffy!
Fuyu will be going up against Snuffy.
There's a lot of indie versus idle Ian.
It's like whoever gets the eye.
Whoever wins has to get rid of the eye.
All right, copy, duplicate.
All right, here are your first matchups for day one.
And also, but don't worry, like, you know, the next other
ones are also going to be day one as well.
ND versus Doll.
ND, oh my gosh, how does it feel like every time I remove
more names, it feels like there's still so many.
the raccoon versus the leprechaun is stuffy gonna win that
pot of gold or is foo gonna run over and get a roadkill
we'll find out soon on 25th alright next up alright time to
delete all of this alright time for you guys to screenshot
the current matchups before I wipe it all out of existence
and then you can only watch it in the rewind alright wiping
it out now all right the next the next matchup roadkill for
dinner and on none is the first the next matchup now you put
that down real quick and on none wait actually guys before I
do it can you guys like can you guys like screenshot this
for me it real fat when i post actually no when i post a
matchup i'll just put it i'll just photoshop it that's
actually a lot easier i feel like aesthetically you could
just screenshot this for your twitter post while you're live
tweeting and then for anyone that screenshots this i can
just go like yoink and just take that screenshot and use it
for my own tweet uh work work smarter not harder anyway
anyway let's put the all right let me just rename let me
copy this folder and then do a duplicate and then wait what
am i okay here you go redo this wait did i duplicate all of
this no wait am i dumb wait don't answer that chat
We're doing it live.
Despite so many events that I've hosted, I'm somehow still
incompetent.
It's actually very impressive at this point.
All right.
Anna Nunn is our first matchup in this bracket.
Who is Anna Nunn going to be facing against?
I must tell lies.
Nia!
Oh my God.
Is ex-prison versus ex-prison?
Let's fucking go.
Fight, fight, fight.
I love it when there's infighting and I'm not involved in
just watching.
Oh my god.
At last I can just watch when the infighting starts and I
don't have to be involved in the drama.
Fight, fight, fight, civil war.
Let's go.
What a script.
Real.
Alright, next up in this matchup.
Araka Luto.
Alright, let me fucking put that in.
Luto is here.
Alright, next up.
Who is Luto gonna fight against?
I like how all the Hall of Stars guys are like dodging each
other at the moment.
It would be Sayu versus Luto.
Alright.
Our announcer is going to be joining the fight.
Let me fucking change this real fast.
Boop, boop, boop.
Hey!
Sayu sweep.
I wonder who's going to win between a fucking...
That shit's it.
If anything, you guys roast better than me anyway.
uh the announcer joins the scuffer seagull versus saiyu say
it coward whatever i say will never be as bad as what chat
says i swear chat is like way more creative and coming up
with like roasts than me because you guys have like a group
effort and then i'd steal your roast and then pose it off as
my own roast and then people be like wow doki you're so
fucking clever and i was like thanks i came the next matchup
wait that's not Juno Nagi give me a sec that is not Asteria
Juno Nagi will be the next one oh my god it's finally
getting smaller the wheel is finally getting smaller we're
almost there way to expose yourself Doki I mean it was
pretty obvious Juno Nagi will be fighting against
a bird and an eel i think birds eat eels don't they i mean i
guess like if if juna's like electric um maybe like she can
zap haka because like birds are what i know from pokemon is
that birds are weak against electricity uh to be fair
everybody's weak against electricity except for like i guess
electric eels uh wait have you said has anyone okay saying
that is like technically like unethical like zapping an
electric eel but i'm just thinking like can like eels get
like can electric eels technically get electrocuted and by
getting electrocuted like do they just like get is it just
like neutral to them or like well can they die from
electricity like that's what what aren't you guys wait they
can't yes as in they'll be okay or yes as in they'll die
like i don't know how would you know how do you guys know
have you guys ever seen it in high enough vault can kill
ears yeah but what how high is high that's the thing how
high is like high enough i'm just i'm just curious i'm just
curious you know all right anyway haka will be fighting a
juna all right let me put that in all right how next up
another removal of the name to spin the wheel.
Spin that wheel.
All right, Philly Inn will be the last matchup for Bracket
2.
Welcome.
Welcome to Fight Club, Philly Inn.
For a legal fight club.
The one you can actually talk about.
All right, Philly Inn will be the last matchup for this.
Will be one of the last matchup for this Bracket.
And who would be fighting today.
Not today, 25th.
Sarah or Ramelea?
Oh, Ramelea!
Philean will be fighting Ramelea for the final matchup for
bracket number two.
I think we're finally, we have one last bracket, guys.
One last bracket for everybody.
Let me just put this in here.
All right, Philean versus Remilia.
All right, guys, I forgot to remove Remilia.
Let me remove.
All right, the final seven.
One person will be lucky and, like, I guess, like, move on
without fighting anybody.
So, one person will be very lucky and they just move on
without fighting.
fighting anybody in the first round so whoever they are
congratulations uh there's so many i feel like the hollow
stars members are actually like dodging each other for a
matchup within hollow star you're so lucky they actually
dodged everybody like how the fuck did they do that all
right guys take the screenshot so i can steal it later take
the screenshot guys nirosamba will be in a show match they
will not be in a tournament structure because we don't know
when the tournament's gonna end so they get to have like so
they will be showing up in the beginning of each day well
not each day one of the days they'll be showing up in one of
the days for the show match the the the match itself will be
a surprise whoever their matchup will be a surprise as well
until the day of the tournament um where you get to see it
live wheel was rigged from the start let's take a screenshot
for bracket number two it's time for bracket number three
let me put all of this back in here all right wheel time
wheel time it's time to spin the wheel for the last bracket
but we're like sort of speed running this a little sarah
will be in the first matchup for bracket number three Let me
put Sarah in right now.
Sarah will be in the first match in the bracket number
three.
Who will Sarah play against?
Doki is dodging the wheel.
I hope I get a free pass.
Please.
Not me!
Shinri will be fighting against Sarah.
Finally, another Hall of Stars.
member Sarah versus Shinri I'm like dodging these fucking
picks right now get me that free entry is get me that free
entry so I don't have to do anything the dokey skip let it
happen I don't want to fight it I want to fucking no no it's
almost there no okay I'm fighting some I'm waiting.
I'm fighting somebody.
It's not rigged if I'm fighting someone.
Guys, I don't even get a free pass.
It's not rigged.
Who am I matching up against?
Who am I?
Maladoki.
Who am I matching up against?
Are you fucking serious?
I will be fighting Axel.
all right i will be going up against axel what the fuck is
this luck we got it's over for who who is it over for who
are you cheering for i'm literally the main event organizer
no finish the story the ultimate showdown Anyway, so I guess
I will be fighting Axel Alright, finally It's Octavio, so I
am Beto, I swear, Beto gets a fucking free pass I swear to
God It's so over Alright Octavio Will be the third matchup
On that day Removed Alright, who will Octavio be fighting
against.
Octavio, either Beto or Sia.
And one person will get to have a free pass.
And that one person is Beto.
Finally, the last two matchups.
Octavio versus Sia.
And Beto versus nobody.
he gets a free pass he gets the fucking lady luck blessing
him today um all right boom all right but here are your
brackets guys bracket three um i don't have bracket one and
two because i literally just overwrite wrote one and two so
like if you want to know where bracket one and two is feel
free to um we're eliminating a lot of holostar members right
off the bat like i don't i don't know how Is that possible?
Because even they survive.
Even they survive here.
Like they have to fight against each other.
So battle versus battle.
You know what?
That'll be fun.
If there's more than one battle wrestler.
We'll have two battles fighting against each other.
And then we'll see whichever battle wins.
Will be the battle representative.
So if there's so many battle fan wrestlers.
We'll have them fight each other.
And then yeah.
And battle two.
Clearly would win the tournament, maybe.
If he's lucky.
Maybe Battle 2 would end up sweeping everything.
Battle 2.
Alright, Battle versus Battle.
I feel like that's like the best.
The mirror match.
Gold bullet is...
will be in a show match.
Go Bullet is not in the tournament, but they will be there
for casting.
They will be there throughout the tournament for
casting-wise, but they said that originally they wanted to
do just casting, but it'll be great if you can be in the
show match, just to even out the show matches.
So anyway, yes, here are all the brackets.
I don't have one and two because I overrode it.
So if you want to know what one and two the brackets were,
please look at Twitter, I guess.
Or rewind this VOD if you are a VOD watching.
So, very professional, Doki.
You've been hosting and organizing events for so long, and
you're still just as incompetent.
Hey, I'm super hyped for this, honestly.
Let me go back to the chatting real quick.
very hyped for uh for wrestle tuber again a huge shout out
to gamer subs for providing um like full out probably the
full sponsor to this event so that i don't have to pay for
anything um including like the the you know the belts the
graphics um everything related to to this event i can't wait
for you guys to see the video when it's done because it was
actually a really sick video and i was gonna play that video
for the announcement
but so many things happened last minute that we couldn't get
the video done in time and i was like i was like i'm so
sorry i'm really sorry i was like i would be like hey like
i'm so sorry to my editor i'll be like oh my god sorry this
is the last minute edition here you go by the way uh octavia
is going to be a caster this is very last minute i'm so
sorry and then literally like two or three hours later i'll
be like i'm so sorry there's another last minute edition
here it is here's the here's the graphic i'm so sorry here's
here's another thing i have to add and and then and then
like and then i'll be like i'm this i swear this is it this
is these are everybody it's it's a hard cap for real this
time so i really apologize to the editor and i'm really
sorry that we couldn't get the video and done but when you
guys see the video it's so cool it's so fucking cool hey
guys i'll be posting all the rules the brackets um all the
information regarding wrestle tuber on um on twitter um all
the information will be there uh the guidelines the rules on
how to make your wrestler uh for the people that will be
using your wrestler to represent them um and again a huge
thank you to all the participants they are giving their own
time to participate in this event um like this was a very
ambitious project for me one of the hardest things i've ever
organized uh solely by myself by the way uh there was no
outside management my management team did not help me
organize this because i chose to do this myself um they
offered but because i felt like i wanted this to be more
less i wanted to be less serious and by not having like
there it gives off a more carefree vibe um a more carefree
vibe a less serious like try hard thing we're all just there
to make memories and enjoy an event together um so like
everything was done uh solely by me when it comes to uh
organizing all of this and reaching out to people and uh and
inviting them to participate uh like i said a huge shout out
to everybody for saying yes to this and for joining the
server and for willing to give their own time because this
event lasts a very long time because we all know how long it
took last time so
so like it's understandable that like super like that like
people were like oh i don't know because it was a very it is
a very long event and uh i originally had a hard cap to be
for participants but then that hard cap became a softer cap
and then and then later on became a hard cap because i was
like oh man that's that was long that's a lot of people
i was like yeah that was a lot of people
um um so please check out all the v-tubers that are
participating, that are giving up their time to be part of
this event, and to just celebrate v-tubing in general.
I hope by doing this, there might be more incentives for
more big events similar to this, where it can unite various
companies and various indies together, just like how we see
it in Japan, of uh shibuya hell and uh and cr and crazy
raccoon and this is basically like uh there's basically
something i want to do equivalent to that and i hope that
this inspires more events like this in the future not just
from me but from other uh but from other people that want to
organize events as well because i feel like like i said this
is what we heavily lacked in the english vtubing or from
indies that are just indies or like or like vtubers and
fleshies or like come within the company but we don't have
events we don't really have events that unite people from
different places and this is why i wanted to do this was
literally my next roadmap uh something i wanted to evolve
into the future with uh so yeah yeah i
really appreciate it guys i really um i really do appreciate
you guys all showing up for this very special announcement
um despite the lots of scuff in the beginning uh because i
am i swear the most unlucky bird ever when it comes to like
important things that i have to do i swear i'm just so
unlucky so i really appreciate you guys sticking around even
though we had a very rough start and being super hyped for
this event a lot of fun both fans and the vtubers alike and
i cannot wait to see what kind of roast they're gonna do to
each other i wonder betta's gonna roast himself i just see
him like looking at the mirror
and then see him so looking at the mirror and being like i'm
better than you hey guys that was the announcement i'm gonna
rest now next week is technically my week except for Tekken
I guess I'll just be grinding Tekken for Sejan slam it's
gonna be a very busy time but I'm gonna hope that next week
is semi rest week because mostly I'll just be grinding
Tekken instead of doing anything else but I might not be
streaming a lot of the Tekken thing I'll definitely be
streaming the fucking rounds I guess of all the stuff that's
going on like the the tournament itself I don't know if I'll
be maybe I'll stream like one practice match uh But who
knows?
Hey, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.